Moses is with us in New York hey Moses
how are you good by the grace of God one
better than I deserve and everything oh
you're doing the same just the same how
can I help ya so I am currently consumer
debt free I have a mortgage to pay I
just bought a house and I was wondering
what your thoughts are on installing
solar panels paid in full in cash yeah
your thoughts on that well they have
come a long way in the last decade in
terms of efficiency and your return on
investment is a lot better than it used
to be obviously some areas of the
country get more Sun than other areas
and so in your particular area they can
do a pretty good analysis and the other
piece of information that enters into it
is the cost of utilities in your area
and so we are in in Tennessee we have a
this thing called TVA the Tennessee
Valley Authority that has worked very
well to keep our utility costs way lower
than most of the rest of the country but
for instance in California where the
utility costs are very high and there's
a lot of Sun it makes a ton of sense to
do solar in an area like kind of C it
can make sense or an area like New York
it can make sense you just would have to
run the numbers out on it and probably
one of the solar guys can give you some
really solid data on it because it has
to do with number of hours of sunshine
in the year and the cost of utilities
gives you your payback on it right
that's your return on investment but the
good news is they have become much more
reasonable in cost and much more
efficient the technology is improving
every day in that world and so I'm a big
fan of solar panels I endorsed them in
several cities around America with local
people that install them and I've looked
at the numbers on those I don't in full
disclosure I don't have them on my home
because I haven't found the way I wanted
to do it I live on the side of a hill
with a lot of wind and so anyway I'm not
doing it but if but mathematically if
you're paying cash for them no payments
in some area
is the return on investment is excellent
in other areas it's good and so you just
look at what your breakeven is and of
course you'd want to break even on them
before you sold the house is the idea
that they increase the value of the
house by the cost of the solar panels is
not true in most areas whole you need to
make your money back on the utility bill
and then if your house brings a little
more because it's got panels on it later
when you sell it fine so in other words
you're going you got to break even on
the solar panel of three and a half
years and you're going to sell your
house in two years you don't want to buy
but if you're going to stay in the home
a long time then you can run the
analysis with some local people in your
area and my general comment is in
general I'm a fan in some areas I'm a
big fan of the math hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]